hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play dead space okay I've been
standing here while this guy isn't
moving
so I'm guess he's gonna go on his own I
don't know why just get up man just go
oh there's a moment he's like me he's
got the pulse rebel because he knows
what so you have to destroy the pods to
bring the air quality up pods I didn't
know something in this store
well that's East is west of it ah store
I don't give me some inventory contact
force energy yeah I need another level
of suit they should be giving me another
level to pretty soon right maybe I don't
know who knows these things
you know I don't trust you I think
you're hiding something about it
Wow hey I'll spray things are those
nothing but locked containers what's the
point of getting in here anyway
and like always enough place are gonna
come back bench yay please
I am almost fully upgraded on my damage
Boswell get it all right and I'll keep
two nodes just in case there are two
towers maybe maybe they're terribly good
at it good average you know
they're locked gimme gimme yeah Emma for
the gun I don't need use all right um I
got destroyed pods I'm not quite sure
what they mean by pods escape pods like
some sort no that's too bad for you oh
what's that you need a dog yeah
reload lucky bow our reload speed is
upgraded to the match this doesn't look
so bad it's like a rain forest in here
kinda nice actually I hear some insects
all right then why would they let
insects in onto a ship that seems like
it would cause problems like a bee's
nest you know whoa hello
well someone bond there we go
thank you
well what's that somebody oh it's
simulated noises okay because it's
scientifically proven that of loud
noises or a high decibel environment
around plants encouraged yeah didn't
think so anyway I'm trying to talk about
science here stop popping out at me it's
theorized that in an environment with
more animals such as birds plants are
more likely to successfully deliver
their seeds across the environment when
other animals are around to eat them and
deliver oh come on I'm talking about
science and therefore
bloom sooners therefore they're
encouraged to roll faster not
necessarily that they grow bigger but
they grow to their maximum size faster
the more you know that has been today's
science lesson all right what do we do
am I going up there nope I'm not where
am I going
now you like that so let's screaming in
your face oh no these aren't even even a
bit of a child but here's some not an
animal
hello what I lost air in here Oh what
are you three bullets all to Wimpy's
help sorry
oh the crew got turned into at enemies
Oh obvious come around the corner
Oh black was not even the challenge
even not time to go racing all right
sorry I'm just being offensive all over
the place all right where are we on here
all right another one hello Oh
all right mercykill fine
can't have you stinking up all the air
not why lock telling me to go through
here I want to go I do I really do
Oh
[Music]
oh hey stop oh you did not why are you
up on the wall I have one of your claws
no ah darn it
oh now they're right outside the door
damn at get open it open it and then and
why is it still convulsing like that
that is just stop it stop it stop
jiggling I see the little things that
are called do that anymore no good that
was more of a hassle than I thought it'd
be where now am I going up yeah I think
I'm going up down okey-dokey whatever
you say magic beam wait wood level on
the gonna I'll start with two
oh I'm the only repair technician left
on this ship and I'm gonna repair it
with bullets
oh so badass okay was this what you do
here what's in that door I want to know
what's up on that floor secret prize
secret secret ah box secret box found it
I'm so awesome oh so slow you think in
the future they would meet they would be
able to make faster elevators oh all
right
nope that was a Miss good job there
Isaac it wasn't secret yay I've found
that's worth 10,000 credits Wow Isaac
can you hit him please
10,000 credits to me oh yeah
all right now take the world's slowest
elevator back down
that's probably why was the secret cuz
no one wanted to go up to the third
floor going this slow all right
[Applause]
there we are okay am i going this way or
that way I'm curious what's this way now
that you know I've got I know that
there's secrets hello all the save
station oh this goes to West wait
haven't I been in West was I in West I
thought this was West let me check just
make sure oh
kaboom exploding guy hello big glowing
target
not sure where I'm going but apparently
that was supposed to happen so maybe
okay uh was it
no error zero gravity I think I'm gonna
hit the door I got left
none exactly not all right okay
oh the baby's out dead
items no how about you all right that's
gonna do it for this episode thank you
guys so much for watching and as always
I will see you in the next bye bye